every film has its fair share of deleted
scenes and while most of the time they
tend to be inconsequential from time to
time a movie can actually be ruined by
leaving the wrong moments on the cutting
room floor he has a look at some major
releases who's editing put a major dent
in everyone's enjoyment the Golden
Compass after the astounding critical
and commercial success of Peter
Jackson's Lord of the Rings trilogy in
the early 2000s New Line Cinema tried to
recapture that glory with another
fantasy trilogy Philip Pullman's Dark
Materials it didn't work since you
probably forgot this movie ever even
existed the studio hired screenwriter
Chris Weitz the helmet adaptation of the
first novel in the trilogy The Golden
Compass starring Daniel Craig Nicole
Kidman and newcomer to Kota Blue
Richards but it was the material that
White's decided to leave out of his
adaptation that sealed the franchise's
fate the book's fans faulted Weitz for
his decision to exclude the novel's over
themes of questioning religion by hiding
them in metaphors the film lost the
novel's essence along the way and was
widely ridiculed for softening a major
component of the story in order to cater
to a wider audience furthermore in order
to accommodate a shorter runtime White's
had to cut out an estimated hour from
his original screenplay
mostly scenes featuring the story's
protagonist al IRA with no support from
the fans and general audiences left
scratching their heads this would be
trilogy was unsurprisingly halted after
a single chapter Batman vs Superman dawn
of Justice there's no denying that the
DC extended universe has been successful
at the box office
however there's also no getting around
the criticisms that have greeted these
movies particularly 2016's Batman vs
Superman dawn of Justice fans and
critics alike blasted the movie for his
haphazard editing and Confused plot
which still resulted in a one hundred
and fifty one minute punch travel gonza
in fact even with over two and a half
hours worth of film many felt several
plot lines and characters were
underdeveloped when editor David Brenner
confirms that the original coat was
almost four hours long it became clear
that the theatrical version really was
as undercooked as it seemed shortly
after the movie's release the studio
released an r-rated Ultimate Edition
which added an additional 30 minutes of
footage critics have said the extended
version is a drastic improvement
expanding upon Lex Luthor's role and
Clark
investigation maybe Zack Snyder will
learn his lesson and make the Justice
League movie the full 14 hour epic we
all know it needs to be that was sarcasm
by the way that would be awful Suicide
Squad after the critical disappointment
that came with Batman vs Superman dawn
of Justice fans hope Suicide Squad would
be a turning point for the DC extended
universe too bad it still earned more
than its share of critical scorn the
unhappiest Critic of all that was Jared
Leto who played the movie's new take on
the Joker although he doesn't appear too
much in the final cut Jared Leto claimed
to have filmed an entire movies worth of
footage as the Joker and considering
that Batman's arch nemesis was such a
big draw in the first place
plenty of people were disappointed when
the filmmakers relegated him to the
background so much so that some fans
have actually attempted to sue the
studio warner brothers extended cut of
Suicide Squad added another 13 minutes
to the runtime shining more light on the
relationship between the Joker and
Harley Quinn as to whether we'll ever
get to see the rest of the Joker footage
the Leto shot as a mystery that not even
Batman can solve Nightbreed based on the
1988 novel cabal by director slash
author Clive Barker Nightbreed follows
mental patient Aaron Boone who believes
he's a serial killer as he run from the
police and joins a group of recluse
monsters known as that's right the
Nightbreed since he wrote both the
source material and the script Barca had
a clear vision one the executives at
20th Century Fox didn't share they
wanted a slasher film with scary
monsters and that wasn't what Barca
delivered with his two-and-a-half hour
cut in response the studio ordered a
series of reshoots and cut almost an
hour out of the final product in the end
Nightbreed was a critical and commercial
failure though it did achieve cult
status among hardcore horror fans
it wasn't until 2014 that a director's
cut saw release running 20 minutes
longer than the theatrical version and
featuring 40 minutes of altered or
unseen footage daredevil mark steven
johnson daredevil from 2003 received
mixed to negative reviews during its
theatrical run but was still moderately
successful becoming the second
highest-grossing february release at the
time shortly afterward johnson put
together a director's cut which was
released the following year it included
additional footage that have been
excised from the theatrical version as
well as
entire subplot featuring a drug addict
named Dante Jackson played by none other
than Coolio and as we learned on the
Syfy original movie pterodactyl the
presence of Coolio can elevate just
about anything you know we could be
famous or something that was out of hand
that nonsense now soldier thank you
while the director's cut went unnoticed
by most the few who saw it agreed that
it turned what was once a mess into a
compelling story Marvel Studios
President Kevin Feige who served as
producer on the film has gone on record
saying I think the people who had other
opinions will be won over by this new
version
perhaps if Johnson's cut of the film
released in theaters instead moviegoers
might have had a different initial
opinion of Ben Affleck when Warner
Brothers cast him as a new Batman and
maybe we'll all be waiting in line for
the latest installment of Coolio's Dante
Jackson spin-off franchise Fantastic
Four in 2015 Josh Trank's Fantastic Four
remake release are overwhelming critical
discontent with the movie winning
Razzies for worst director worst remake
worst screenplay and worst picture much
of the film's issues have been pinned on
trunk though he's claimed an exceptional
cut of the film does indeed exist but
we'll never see it one day prior to the
movie arriving in the theaters Trang
took to Twitter and responded to the
critical backlash saying a year ago I
had a fantastic version of this and it
would have received great reviews you'll
probably never see it that's reality
though although many people would
consider tranqs tweets to be the
rumblings of a disgruntled director Toby
Kebbell who plays a villain Doctor Doom
attested to the same thing telling The
Daily Beast I tell you the honest truth
is trying to did cut a great film that
you'll never see that is a shame a much
darker version and you'll never see it
as for what we can see the week kate
mara wore drawing the movie 3 shoots so
you know win some lose some thanks for
watching click the looper icon to
subscribe to our YouTube channel plus
check out all this cool stuff we know
your love
you